we had a beautiful sunny Sunday here in
the northeast of the United States that
includes Boston and includes New York it
includes Washington DC and Donald Trump
spent that sunny Sunday exploding on
Twitter and continuing this morning
there are some interesting vocabulary
analyses being done of Donald Trump's
speech and tweets that show significant
and continued deterioration I'm not
going to deal with that today we're
gonna deal with that tomorrow the topic
today is the predicted predictable
erratic escalation of Donald Trump
since being acquitted of impeachment we
knew it would happen and it's happening
we don't even have the time to go
through Donald Trump's tweets
individually here because there are so
many and they are so unhinged but let's
look at just some of them and I will
summarize others now understand that
Donald Trump spent the better part of
the last two days tweeting the president
has tweeted almost uninterruptedly for
the last two days aside from the content
of the tweets this is not normal the
targets included the fake news media
polling craze Democrats New York's
leaders the TV show Face the Nation Adam
Schiff Mitt Romney Joe Manchin Jerry
Nadler a polling professional named
Larry Sabato and many many more Trump
tweeting about how he's we winning in
New Hampshire but the fake news media
won't tell you that tweeting about crazy
Nancy Pelosi's impeachment hoax which
has lifted Republican Congressional
polls and my polls he says way up which
was expected but it has had a great
effect on Republican Senate races
including in a bunch of different states
thanks he says tweeting about the crazed
Dems saying they will do anything
honesty and truth don't matter to them
they are badly wounded Iowa vote count
was a disaster for them then retweeting
all sorts of what I call a j't
type videos dozens and dozens over a
period of many hours then going in on
Republican senator Mitt Romney the only
Republican to vote guilty and Trump's
impeachment on either article remember
Romney voted guilty just on article
not guilty on article two trump saying
romney hurts some very good republican
senators and he was wrong about the
impeachment hoax no clue
remember that mit romney is reportedly
now on donald trump's enemies to get
revenge on list told you about that last
week
attacking Democratic Senator Joe Manchin
as quote they are really mad at Senator
Joe munchkin in West Virginia it's
actually kind of funny he couldn't
understand the transcripts remember
those were never released Romney could
but didn't want to and then really
ramping up the caps-lock tweets remember
as we've said before when Trump is so up
to defend Trump in my email in live
streams tweeting to me on my Facebook
page they engage caps-lock
and turn off spellcheck and Donald Trump
doing the some of the same here starting
FBI director Christopher Rae just
admitted that the FISA warrants and
surveillance of my campaign were illegal
misspelled surveillance so was the fake
dossier caps lock therefore the whole
scam investigation the molar report and
everything else for three years was a
fixed hoax who pays the price and then
going into an almost completely
capitalized tweet to follow up this is
the biggest political crime in American
history capitalizing history by far
capslock simply put the party in power
illegally spied on my campaign both
before and after the election in order
to change or nullify the results of the
election it continued on with the
impeachment hoax terrible and it
continues then a couple of short tweets
drain the swamp all in caps make America
great again keep America great again in
all caps and then as of this recording
Trump with a four tweet combo today
about the New Hampshire rally that he
has tonight going after AOC going after
Chuck Schumer going after the fake news
media and much more guys this isn't
normal no other President behave this
way there are two sides to this you can
look at the content of Donald Trump's
tweets which is absolutely unhinged
erratic and ridiculous but then you can
say forget about the content he's
tweeting sometimes hundreds of time
in a day tweets and retweets that alone
he could be tweeting about his deep
knowledge of philosophy and it would
still be weird for a president to be
tweeting this much other presidents did
stuff most days even if they did things
that we didn't like they were doing
things foreign leaders work on things
while Trump's attention spans seemingly
prevents him from having an in-depth
meeting without his attention drifting
to a TV showing Fox News in the back of
the room his briefings are down to a
single page two bullet points and a
picture based on reporting from inside
the White House and he is just tweeting
all day the one I don't even know to
call it a silver lining but the one
response that sometimes people have to
the endless erratic unhinged tweeting is
that if he's spending this much time
tweeting he's spending less time doing
things that damage the country that's
the one pseudo silver lining that
sometimes people find we're gonna have
more about this on the shows Instagram
page make sure you were following it at
david pakman show and make sure you
follow me on instagram at david pakman I
posted a pretty pretty wacky hate mail I
got this morning on my Instagram page at
David Pakman I want to encourage
everybody in my audience to go subscribe
to a YouTube channel we're partnering
with it's called up flip they release
new videos every week in every video you
meet a different entrepreneur and get an
in-depth look at how their business
works and how they became successful
it's great if you like shows like shark
tank if you own your own business or
you're thinking of starting one the up
flip YouTube channel really does offer a
wealth of knowledge and inspiration as
an entrepreneur myself and a business
owner I've really been enjoying hearing
all of the different stories of the
people that they interview but it's
really fascinating content even if you
don't own your own business to go check
out the up flip youtube channel they're
friends of the David Pakman show I'd
love it if you would support them by
subscribing to their channel you can
find the up flip YouTube channel by
going to david pakman.com slash up flip
you're watching this on youtube i've put
the link right underneath this video